my name is Jan broberg Robert birchtold  kidnapped me when I was 12 and again  when I was 14 and with that my  brainwashing began  he was a master manipulator you had  intimate relations with Robert and your  husband your dad had intimate relations  with Robert yep yep it's insane  there must be a special place in hell  for people that hurt children  do I really want to do this I gotta face  the demon this was the torture chamber  and that's the moment that my child  could end it somebody help me I'm here  the same things that happened to me  happened to her it's the first time that  she spoken publicly he said this is our  secret how do we make it stop I'm angry  and I'm sad for a fat little girl this  is the beginning of the journey to  Healing